you want people looking down on you like  those people who drop cadillac's you  want a one percenter you want an elite  illuminati then go get your prosciutto  if you want a person who's gonna take  over this country and lead the  revolution that's salami saying you  would have a different kind of celebrity  for that titan versus titanium no you're  saying what would you go to a  charcuterie board and what's the lobby  for you you cut off little pieces cut  off little pieces cut off little pieces  be sure you don't get that you already  get already sliced or forget it that's  wrong how is it wrong that's wrong how  wrong you're wrong there are different  shapes of prosciuttos yeah and you can  cut the meat however the [ __ ] you want  to cut how how i've only seen it in deli  form i've only seen it in deli meat  formula thinly sliced trash  you you you l you live in squalor